everyone welcome to this next episode of
your daily equation today I will focus
upon the Euler Lagrange equations yeah
it's a bit of a mouthful but the
equations that I'm gonna talk about are
really absolutely central to all of
modern theoretical physics I mean if you
go into the office of any physicist a
theorist and experimentalist and you
look at their blackboard or you look at
the papers that they're reading or you
look at the papers that they're writing
you will see some version of the
equations that I will discuss here today
now with that kind of a broad imprint I
could use many many examples to develop
the subject I'm going to use the
simplest possible example a single
particle moving in one spatial dimension
nonrelativistic aliy as with that basic
example we can get the basic idea of the
subject most simply so let me just jump
right in then to that so object so we
are talking about who I should make sure
sorry about that I should first bring up
my iPad good it's on the screen so we
are talking about the Euler Lagrangian
which is also something that goes under
the name of the principle principle of
least action so the least action
principle Euler Lagrange equations
tightly tightly related as we will see
now oiler and LeGrande clearly were
vital to the subject but perhaps it's
worth noting that many physicists over
the decades in the centuries played a
role in developing refining these ideas
let me just show some of their pictures
you can bring my
imagery up on the screen here so here's
Vermont played a role in the early
development Pertwee as well oiler of
course his name is in the subject
Lagrange's well Hamilton others Jacoby
so it's just to show that that so many
people early on realized that these
equations were really central and
deserved the attention they require to
fully develop them and therefore many
people expended effort on that not just
Euler and LaGrange but let me now focus
upon the basic idea in a simple example
so we can understand where things are
coming from and to do that I think it's
quite useful to start with how Newton
would describe the motion of a single
non relativistic particle in one
dimension so that we've out a real sunny
day here I've got to dodge the Sun as I
am moving around here so sorry about all
the motion but how would Newton describe
the motion of such a particle he would
say who say hey give me the position of
the particle at the initial time zero
called that position x0 he'd say give me
the velocity or in one spatial dimension
you me the speed of the particle
initially at time zero call that v-0 and
then he would say all you need to do is
use my famous second law of motion F
equals MA in order to work out the
trajectory of the particle and for the
special kinds of forces that I'm going
to focus attention on here conservative
forces the force can be written as the
derivative of a potential with respect
to position the acceleration itself well
that's the second derivative of the
position with respect to time and by the
way as a matter of notation to make it
easy we often write a dot for a first
derivative two dots for a second
derivative just a nice little shorthand
that in this particular case for a
velocity that be X dot for acceleration
that's MX double dot but the bottom line
is we now have a nice differential
equation
in here that given a potential that is
given a force you simply solve this
differential equation subject to this
initial condition data that we have over
here and from that you will derive a
solution called X of T which is the
desired trajectory of that particle of
moving under that particular force and
this is the standard approach that you
know you teach it in high school you
solve the differential equations and you
come up with trajectories what I want to
do now is show a completely different
looking approach ultimately it is
equivalent but it looks completely
different has a completely different
conceptual structure and that is this
approach that makes use of this least
action principle how does that approach
go well let me draw a little line here
to distinguish it from the outset and
I'll call this the least action approach
and the idea here is you start by not
giving this kind of data the position
and speed of the particle initially
instead what you provide here is X at
time 0 as in the Newtonian approach but
now you don't give me the speed at time
0 you give me the final position of the
particle at final time they'll call
capital T let's call that position X of
T and you'll note I'm drawing the
positions as if they can be scattered in
two or higher number of dimensions it is
more fun to write things that way but
the math I'm going to focus on from the
get-go will be in one spatial dimension
but imagine that you know you have a
trajectory that connects these points
and in this approach the idea is that we
are going to look at all possible
trajectories that start at the initial
point and end at the final point you
know I can't draw them all but I can
draw a nice healthy assortment of them
see here a whole bunch of
trajectories that go from the initial
point to the final point and in the
least action formalism what we do is the
following to each of those trajectories
we assign a number that number is called
the action so for each trajectory let me
call the trajectory say X sub I of T so
maybe this one here is x1 of T and this
is x2 of T and so on maybe this is X n
of T whatever so the action I'm going to
give you the formula for the number that
you ascribe to a given trajectory in
half a second but for the moment just
note that I have some number associated
with each trajectory and all we do
according to the least action principle
is find that trajectory that gives you
the minimum value of that number the
minimum value of what we call the action
and when you minimize or more generally
extremize the action but let me avoid
those kind of mathematical subtleties
just to get the essential idea here when
you minimize the action when you find a
trajectory that gives you the smallest
value of this number you are done
according to this approach that is the
trajectory that the classical particle
will actually follow now I need to give
you the formula for the action
associated to a given path a given
trajectory and let me just give you that
so if you give me a trajectory X of T
the idea is I look at the integral from
T equals 0 to T equals T and for the
integrand let me just give it another
color to make it look nicer I take the
kinetic energy of the particle at time T
following that path I subtract from that
the potential energy of the particle at
time T and I integrate this with respect
to T integration of course is nothing
but a fancy name for summation so for
instance I would calculate for this
orange e or is that you
or light Arne's whatever for this
particular trajectory I'd calculate
kinetic energy minus potential energy
there I'd added to kinetic energy minus
potential energy there and I'd add up
all of these contributions and when I do
that that would give me the action
associated with that that particular
path okay now look I have to admit when
you see this combination it's a little
weird we're used to kinetic energy being
added to potential energy after all the
guy that would give us the total energy
of the particle but here we're doing
something that looks a little weird at
first sight we're subtracting the
potential energy from the kinetic energy
but as we will see that is the right
combination in order that when we find
the trajector that minimizes that
particular number this guy over here we
will indeed recover the classical
trajectory that Isaac Newton would give
us via this formalism up here and in
fact let me let me do that right now let
me show you how to minimize this action
and as we will see we will recover
Newton's equations from it okay so how
do you minimize over trajectories that
sounds pretty tough right well the way
we do it it's a subject called the
countless of variations I could develop
you know an episode explaining that in
its own right but let me just work
intuitively motivated by things that
hopefully you are familiar with from
standard calculus look if you haven't
taken standard calculus it's gonna be a
little hard to follow what I'm talking
about here in detail but you know as
I've said in many of these episodes you
can follow what I'm talking about at a
variety of levels if you just want to
let the symbols wash over you they're
kind of beautiful pretty to look at
that's cool but if you've had some
calculus what I'm going to say right now
is straightforward and the
generalization I think you'll be able to
take that leap with me so what is the
notion from calculus that we need well
if you have a function y of X one of the
most basic things that you do in
calculus is you find say the minimum of
that function y of X and that minimum in
this case is right over here and I can
just draw a nice little tangent line at
that location and the way you find that
minimum in standard calculus is you look
at dy/dx and you set that equal to zero
and that indeed picks out the extreme of
the maximum the minimum saddle points
more generally but here let's just talk
about the minimum it picks out that
location right there
now another an equivalent way of saying
this is if we consider the function y of
X we can also consider what we'll call
Delta Y of X which I will define to be Y
of X plus a little change in X minus y
of X the idea being that I can imagine
going a little bit to the left or a
little bit to the right of the minimum
itself and they claim is that if indeed
the red dot is the minimum of the
function then this guy Delta Y of X to
first order in this little variation in
the location of X will be equal to 0
it'll vanish the first order in the
variation of the independent argument
how do we do that well it's completely
straightforward this can be written as
using first order Taylor expansion of Y
of X plus Delta X so this is equal to Y
of X plus dy/dx times Delta X there'd be
higher order terms in general but I'm
only going to work to first order that
will be enough for us minus y of X this
guy over here so this Delta Y of X is
nothing but dy DX times Delta X and if
we are expanding about the minimum then
this term indeed is equal to 0 and
therefore the entire thing is equal to 0
so the variation of Y is equal to 0 when
we are looking at the
variation about an extreme point or in
this particular case about the minimum
and I'm going to play exactly the same
game to find the minimum of the action
just as to find the minimum of the
function I set the first order variation
with respect to the independent argument
equal to zero to find the minimum of the
action I'm going to look at the
variation of the action and I'm going to
set that equal to zero to first order in
now the variation of the independent
argument and the independent argument
this case is a little bit more
complicated here's where the leap comes
in because s is not a function of X it's
rather a functional you have to put in a
full trajectory to get at this
expression that we have over here but
you know we can imagine playing the same
game as in the simple calculus example
and namely define this to be equal to s
of X of T plus Delta X of t minus s of X
of T and we are going to demand that
this is equal to zero to first order now
in the variation Delta X of T so what
are we're actually doing here in
pictorial form is let me choose a nice
little color over here if this is our
initial point x0 and this is our final
point X sub T and imagine that we have
indeed located the extremal path the
path would say minimizes the action the
way we will know that that actually is
the extremal path we will look at small
variations arbitrary small variations of
that trajectory and we will demand that
the value of the action along the red
trajectory is equal to the value of the
action along the blue trajectory to
first order in the variation between the
two which is given by this small change
in the trajectory called Delta X
of T and again it's just motivated by
what we did in the calculus example over
here we knew that we had a minimum of
the function y of X if when we moved
away from that purported minimum a
little bit in this direction or a little
bit in that direction the variation of
the function was equal to zero to
first-order similarly if the variation
of the action is equal to zero to
first-order then we will have found the
trajectory that minimizes or extreme
lies is the action that's the strategy
that we will follow so now all we need
to do is write this expression out in
more detail namely making use of X of T
itself very X of T subtract out its
value at X of T and see what function we
are left with what formula we're left
with so let's do that now to that end
let me write down s of X of T I wrote it
schematically above here kinetic energy
minus potential energy kinetic energy is
one-half MV squared V is X dot so I can
simply write this a little bit more
explicitly as the integral from 0 to T
of one-half M X dot squared minus V of X
integrated DT X is X of T all right now
to play the game I need to now write
down s of X of T plus Delta X of T I do
a small variation in the initial
trajectory and this will give me and to
go from T equals 0 to T of 1/2 M let's
just put X dot plus Delta X dot squared
minus V of X plus Delta X integrate this
with respect to T already now what I
want to do is subtract this fella from
this fella and to do that it behooves me
to expand what I have here on the
right-hand side to first order in Delta
X so I'm going to throw away
any higher order terms any delta X
squares or Delta X dot squares that will
be very small in the limit that Delta X
itself is small so I can drop those in
the approach that I am taking so let me
now expand what I have there on the
right-hand side and that's
straightforward to do it's the integral
from T equal to 0 to T 1/2 ok expanding
that square the first term will give me
M X dot squared the cross terms will
give me a factor of 2 that kills the
half so I'll get M times X dot times
Delta X dot the last term over here will
give me Delta X dot squared I'm throwing
that away from the gecko ok now let me
expand this term and that I can do much
as I did my function Y if I'm expanding
in a Taylor series expansion to first
order I'd simply replace this Y by a V
and therefore I look at minus V of X the
first term minus DV DX times Delta X the
second term and again there would be
higher order terms in the expansion of
that function V of X I drop them all I'm
just working to first order in the
variation that is all that I need to do
to get the minimum of the action itself
ok so now I've expanded the s the action
at the slightly varied trajectory and I
need to subtract from that the action at
the original trajectory and medially you
see some cancellations that will happen
so when I subtract this term from this
expression this guy will go away and let
me use a different color just to
highlight that no dark green here this
guy will go to 0 from subtracting this
term when I subtract the V of X it will
cancel against the similar term that we
have here so the variation of the action
then to first order the only terms that
will remain will be this term and this
term so you have the in
Rolle DT of M X dot Delta X dot minus DV
DX Delta X integrated DT now we're
almost there what we do need to do
though is it's more useful to not have a
delta X dot but have everything
proportional to Delta X itself how can
we do that well a little side
calculation shows us how we do that so
if I consider and this is standard
integration by parts in calculus so
there's no magic going on here but let
me just write it down if I consider D by
DT of the expression M X dot times Delta
X what will I get
well I get M times and when the
derivative hits this term I'll get X
double dot times Delta X and when the
derivative hits this term I'll get M X
dot times Delta X dot now look the
second term is exactly what we want and
therefore I can write M X dot Delta X
dot as being equal to D by DT of M X dot
Delta X minus M X double dot Delta X so
now I'm going to take this term and put
it in place of the first term so I'll
have Delta s is equal to the integral DT
of D by DT of M X dot Delta X minus M X
double dot Delta X and then we have over
here where I left out the x over here we
will have minus DV DX times Delta X and
it's this whole thing integrated with
respect to T now the reason I put it in
this form with a little bit of hindsight
is that I can integrate this first term
easily I'm integrating against a total
derivative so that just gives me the
integrand M X dot Delta X evaluated
between T equal to 0 and T equal
tea for that first term what remains is
- M X dot Delta X integrated that guy
and let me put them all together so that
minus sign means that this guy should be
a plus sign so that the minus and the
plus will conspire to give me that minus
sign they rid of that dot it looks a
little bit weird
Plus DV live come on DV DX times Delta X
now we only have Delta X's left over I
like that as you'll see in a moment it's
quite useful what about this first term
over here well bear in mind that the
variations in the trajectories that we
are looking at let me go back to my
picture over here you have all these
different trajectories but all of them
start and end at the same spot which
means the variation in a trajectory
doesn't change the starting point or the
ending whoa that's the anchor of the
whole analysis which means that Delta X
at time zero is equal to zero which is
equal to Delta X at time T and that's
what comes in to this evaluation and
therefore the first term drops out
beautiful what about the remaining terms
well the remaining term is equal to
minus the integral of a dot over there M
X double dot plus DV DX all of this
Delta X integrated DT from zero to T and
that's what we are left with this little
calculation of the variation of the
action to first order now this is meant
to be zero for any and all variations of
the trajectory that minimizes the action
and for this to be zero for any and all
values of Delta X there's only one way
for that to happen this term over here
must itself be equal to zero so the
conclusion that we get therefore is
Delta s equal to zero
implies that M X double dot plus DV DX
is equal to zero in other words minus DV
DX must be equal to M X double dot let
me box this because this is our final
equation and lo and behold the least
action principle Delta s equal to zero
gives us this equation and if we scroll
all the way back to where we began with
Isaac Newton you will look we have the
same equation minus DV DX equals MX
double dot coming from Isaac Newton and
from this least action principle we now
have the same equation and therefore
they are equivalent to each other even
though they kind of conceptually feel
completely different right conceptually
they they really are completely
different and let me just spell out the
kind of comparison between them so that
you can sort of have in mind the more
philosophical or the more overarching
distinctions between these two very
different looking approaches to get the
classical trajectory of this particle so
by comparison just to sort of write out
the differences between them
you will note that from the standpoint
of the initial data so Newton wants
initial conditions where you give the
position and the velocity of the
particle at the initial time whereas
this least action approach you don't
give the initial conditions at time 0
rather you give what can be called
boundary values the boundary values in
the case that we studied are the
boundary locations of the trajectory the
position at time 0 but the position at
the final time not the initial speed
that's kind of conceptually quite diff
from the usual way that we set up a
Newtonian problem what are the other
comparisons well in addition to the
initial conditions please note that in
general when you do Newtonian mechanics
using F equals MA F is a vector
acceleration is a vector velocity is a
vector I've done the simplest case of
one dimensional motion so I didn't have
to worry about the vectors but you know
if you have taken high school physics or
college-level physics one of the big
headaches of Newtonian mechanics is
keeping track of the components of
vectors that can be pointing this way
that way and so forth and that's really
where a lot of the technical
difficulties that students face arises
but you'll note that in this least
action approach everything from the
starting point is in terms of scalar
quantities right if we are looking at
our form here kinetic energy that's a
number that's not a vector potential
energy that's a number not a vector so
the action over which you are minimizing
is itself described totally in terms of
scalar quantities which makes life so
much easier the vector quantities if you
will they come out of the minimization
process but that's something that you as
the user don't have to worry about you
just turn the crank and minimize this
scalar quantity and it takes care of all
of the vector components for you one
final comparison between these is that
look the the Newtonian description is
completely local right you only talk
about the force acting on the particle
at a given location you don't talk about
the global trajectory that emerges from
solving the differential equation that
comes from F equals MA but in this least
action approach its global from the
get-go
right the way we set up the prop
problem is we are looking if I can go
back to my picture we're looking over
here at the whole trajectory from the
get-go we're looking in fact at the
whole trajectory for many possible
trajectories for in some sense all
possible trajectories and we're
minimizing over that global picture so
again philosophically conceptually it's
quite different newton is starting local
whereas this least action principle is
starting global but yet as we just
showed they are equivalent to each other
at least in the case that i have spelled
out this case of a single particle non
relativistic moving in one spatial
dimension but i assure you that the
equivalent holds true in any more
general circumstance in fact let me
finish up by just showing you the more
general version of the equations and the
general version is indeed where we come
to the so-called Euler Lagrangian of the
general setup and I don't really have to
do much work here because it's just a
generalization of the simpler case no
new conceptual ideas but let me just
quickly run through it for you here so
the general case is you start with
something the action and in the general
case you write down the action as an
integral say from T equal to 0 to T
equal to T of something called the
Lagrangian here's where Lagrange's name
comes into the story and in general that
is a function of positions velocities
and time and you can integrate this with
respect to T in order to get the act not
you can you must integrate it with
respect to T to get the action in the
special case that we focused upon the
Lagrangian itself was simply equal to
the kinetic energy which we know depends
upon X dot velocity it's one-half M V
squared one-half M X dot squared minus
the potential and that's where the X
comes into the story but again that's
just one spell
so case the general situation you could
have up to certain mathematical
restrictions an arbitrary function of
position velocity and time and now to
get the equations of motion the Euler
Lagrange equations we impose that the
variation of s equals zero by which we
mean the same thing that we meant before
we take a purported minimizing
trajectory we add a slight variation of
that trajectory we plug that into the
action we subtract from that the action
around the purported minimizing
trajectory we call this Delta X and we
set this equal to zero to nail down what
the minimum trajectory is and I can
write down the version of the general
equations which will generalize this
simple formula we had in the case that
the Lagrangian is this very special form
and it's not hard for me to do that I'm
wondering if I should derive them up for
I should just write down the end maybe
it's getting late so I'm going to just
write down the answer I'll leave it to
you as a challenge to work this out but
it is nothing different from what I did
in the special case so if you generalize
that you will get to the following
equation the equation is d by DT of the
variation of the Lagrangian with respect
to X dot minus the variation of the
Lagrangian with respect to X is equal to
zero and the Ox here doesn't need to be
one-dimensional it can stand for a whole
variety of coordinates so-called
generalized coordinates but you can
think about them as XY and Z if that
makes it easier to think about I'm gonna
put a little eye on each one of these to
signify that it's one of a grand
collection of coordinates that describes
a given physical system and the solution
to this set of equations is indeed the
minimizing or extreme izing for
Jek turi in the generalized sense for
the action that we started with over
here and so if I were to plug in l
equals kinetic energy minus potential
energy
I would recover the equation that I have
here but in the general case these are
the classical equations for X I of T
that extremize or in my looser language
minimize the action subject to fixing
the boundary conditions on each one of
those variables so that is what I wanted
to get to today the Euler Lagrange
equations let me finish up by just
noting one curious fact that we will
come back to in a later episode which is
you know as Richard Fineman pointed out
it's a little bit wasteful in a sense
that you define this function or
functional and immediately you only make
use of it at one trajectory the
trajectory that minimizes the action
what about the other trajectories that
don't minimize the action do they have
any role in physics and the startling
idea that Richard Feynman came up with
is that they do have a role not in
classical physics classical physics only
focus upon trajectories that minimize
the action but as we will see in a later
episode quantum physics quantum physics
makes use of all of the trajectories so
in a sense classical physics fits within
quantum mechanics by virtue of it
focusing upon very special trajectories
those that extremize or minimize the
action quantum mechanics looks at a more
broad description and a more accurate
description of reality that takes into
account all of jus trajectories should
say all of the tried
factories it's getting a little bit late
my speech is starting to become a little
bit slurred I'm gonna try the team a
third time quantum mechanics make use of
all of the trajectories okay I finally
got it out but that's the key physical
idea and we're going to come back to
that notion in a subsequent episode okay
that's it for today I just wanted to get
to these Euler Lagrange equations and
until next time take care